breaking at four North Las Vegas Police
releasing body cam video in a police
shooting that happened last Friday
during a traffic stop officers say they
walked up to the driver who reached into
the glove box and pulled out a gun thank
you for joining us at 4 I'm Kirsten
Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus two officers
then opened fire and struck the man the
driver died on the scene a warning some
may find this video disturbing
check your vehicle off all right give me
your driver's license stop reaching in
the freaking hey
both officers have now been placed on
administrative leave 8 news now is not
able to attend the briefing as North Las
Vegas Police did not schedule a press
conference and sent this information in
a video our reporters were then not able
to ask any questions